J'ai un métier un petit peu particulier, un métier qui n'existait pas il y a quelques années.
Je suis auteur, comédien, réalisateur, monteur, producteur de vidéos sur Internet
Ouais t'es youtubeur quoi...
C'est ça.. voilà... Je suis youtubeur.
- "Auteur, comédien, réalisateur" ? Pour qui il se prend le mec ?
Dans quelques années, je pense que tout le monde saura ce que c'est, on va arrêter de se poser des questions
on saura très bien ce que c'est un youtubeur, mais pour l'instant... c'est le gros bordel !
Mon métier vu par ma grand-mère
Jambon-beurre ? C'est... C'est pas un métier ça.
Par mon voisin
(derrière le mur) [...] auteur, comédien...
Chérie, le voisin il parle encore tout seul... J'appelle une ambulance ?
La police ! J'appelle la police.
Par une marque
Il peut tenir ce panneau dans sa prochaine vidéo ? Histoire de 5 minutes, on n'est pas non plus ...
Par un hater
Ouais c'est trop d'la merde, j'préfère Pierre Desproges, c'est un autre youtubeur...
Par un enfant
Plus tard j'veux être youtubeur !
Par sa mère
Non youtubeur c'est pas un métier !
Par un journaliste
Argent, argent, argent... Et j'ai terminé mon article ! $$$
Par la mère de l'enfant
Ah ouais ! Mon fils, tu vas faire youtubeur !
Par un businessman
Je vais faire payer des cours pour être youtubeur, bien ou pas ?
Hop hop hop hop, attendez, qu'est-ce que je viens de découvrir la ?
Une école pour être "STAR DU NET" !
"STAR DU NET UN VRAI MÉTIER, RASSURE TA MÈRE"
Laissez ma mère en dehors de ça s'il vous plaît...
Ça parle pas de devenir vidéaste ou auteur... Mais bien star ! Une star comme euh... JEREMSTAR !
Et que proposent les formations ? Qui vont jusqu'à 1500€...
*tousse*
L'optimisation, la monétisation, les partenariats.
Wow, ça annonce des vidéos de qualité !
Tout ce qu'on adore chez un youtubeur, finalement, un youtubeur optimisé, monétisé, partenarié
Bon, si vous voulez pas dépenser 1500€,
*tousse toujours*
Je vais vous donner un cours gratuit pour réussir, à coup sûr, sur Internet !
--Le cours de professeur Cyprien--
Bonjour ! Ça va être un petit peu long , prenez des notes j'vais pas répéter : Faites des bonnes vidéos, régulièrement.
Bonne journée.
--C'était le cours de professeur Cyprien, star de Youtube, sa mère est rassurée--
Bon voilà c'est cadeau, ça me fait plaisir... Non gardez votre argent ! Non, c'est bon !
Sinon en école qui peut vous servir sur YouTube, il y a les écoles d'audiovisuel  pour apprendre le montage,
le cadrage, la lumière, le son, ça peut toujours servir.
Depuis que je fais des vidéos sur Internet, j'analyse tout ce que je vois et je prends des notes sur mon téléphone.
Ce qui me fait marrer comme ça,  ça me servira pour une prochaine vidéo, un court-métrage, une BD...
Comme une idée ça peut arriver à n'importe quel moment, ça peut faire un peu bizarre pour mon entourage, parfois.
- Cyprien, il faut que je te dise quelque chose...
- Ouais ?
- J'ai vu mon médecin... Il m'a annoncé que j'avais une grave maladie incurable et que je risque de mourrir dans les pro...
Ah d'accord tu t'en bats les couilles de ce que je raconte en fait ?
- Comment t'écris "Catapulte" ?
- C-O-N-N-A-R-D. "Catapulte".
Bon par contre mes notes c'est écrit n'importe comment et 90% ne servira jamais à rien.
"Les filles sur Instagram, elles ont des démangeaisons, elles se grattent la tête tout le temps"
- Ah... Ça démange, c'est ignoble..
- PHOTO !
- Je dois avoir des lentes, j'pense...
Euh...
J'sais pas pourquoi j'ai noté ça mais... C'est là.
À quoi ressemblent mes journées de youtubeur ?
Tout les matins, je lis mes mails. C'est un peu mon petit rituel. Malheureusement, j'peux pas répondre à tout le monde...
Et tout les matins j'ai des petites pépites ! :
"Bonjour Cyprien , tu peux venir à mon anniversaire samedi prochain ?"
Malheureusement j'ai un truc Samedi, je suis... Ah je suis deg parce que là
Un bon anniversaire de quelqu'un que j'connais pas, c'est ce que je préfère !
"Bonjour Cyprien, tu peux parler de ma chaîne YouTube ? Je veux faire le buzz"
En tout cas y'a une bonne école pour toi , rassure ta mère , y'a une bonne école pour faire un bon métier
"Bonjour Norman"
...
Voilà , ce genre de mail...
Mes journées sont toutes un petit peu différentes mais y'a des choses qui prennent plus ou moins de temps
Le plus important , c'est l'écriture.
Je passe beaucoup de temps à écrire.
En ce moment j'écris des vidéos pour YouTube, deux courts métrages, une série Roger et ses humains Tome 2
et deux jeux vidéos.
y'a des choses que j'écris tout seul , d'autres que j'écris à plusieurs et surtout je suis spécialiste de la
désorganisation du coup j'écris tout en même temps pas très rapidement comme ça ça avance pas vite.
Si vous voulez des conseils d'écriture pour pas avancer vite...
Ensuite nous avons les tournages ça prend quelques jours et le montage aussi des vidéos quelques jours aussi.
Et il est vrai de temps en temps je m'autorise à jouer à des jeux vidéos , je m'excuse ! Je m'excuse ! Je suis désolé !
Depuis que je suis youtubeur j'ai croisé plein de gens qui m'ont sorti une phrase un peu bizarre :
Vous voyez la fuite elle est juste là..
-Hé mais vous êtes pas le mec de YouTube ?
-Ouais c'est moi , ouais.
-Hé , "faites pas une vidéo sur moi !"
-C'est marrant comme avertissement , comme si je faisais des vidéos sur toutes les personnes que je croise 5 minutes
-Chérie aujourd'hui j'ai vu le mec de YouTube là.
Tiens , il sort une nouvelle vidéo regarde :
"Aujourd'hui j'vais vous parler de mon plombier..."
Oh non il vient de faire une vidéo sur moi !
*Discussion incompréhensible*
Plombier: Mais oui! Je lui ai dit! J'ai prévenu! Je veux pas! Et il le fait!
Chaque année des vies sont brisées par les youtubeurs.
YouTube ça évolue énormément moi j'ai créé ma chaine en 2007
J'me rapelle encore des débuts :
-Alors la vidéo que t'as posté hier ?
-200 vues
...
-200 VUES ?! OUAHHH
-MAIS OUI C'EST UN TRUC DE MALADE , 200 PERSONNES QUE JE NE CONNAIS PAS
-C'EST UN TRUC DE FOU !
- J'AI 7 ABONNÉS !
- 7 ABONNÉS, IL A 7 ABONNÉS CE MEC EST UNE STAR !
-Aujourd'hui c'est plus pareil...
-Ça va ?
-Non j'suis dégouté , j'ai sorti ma vidéo hier elle à fait que 800 000 vues...
-Ah ouais nan...c'est pas...
Rassure-moi , t'as fait la recette du buzz ?
-Bien sur sur la miniature j'ai fait une grimace, un contour blanc, une fille un titre en majuscule
l'interaction avec les internautes.
-J'suis désolé mais si ça continue comme ça tu vas devoir...
-Oh non !
-Si
-Ah si , tu vas devoir avoir de l'imagination
-NOOOOOON POURQUOI MOI ?!
Y'a un aspect , dans le fait d'être youtubeur avec lequel je suis le moins à l'aise
C'est le fait d'être une personnalitée publique
tout ce que je dis va être analysé, décortiqué, sorti du contexte... Je peux dire par exemple sur twitter :
"J'aime bien Jurassic Park"
-Placement de produit pour Jurassic Park
-Ah c'est sûr il préfère parler des blockbusters que les documentaires sur les bombardements en Syrie.
-Cyprien il s'en fout de ce qu'il se passe à l'étranger ça...
-Cyprien n'aime pas les étrangers, je vais le dire sur twitter.
-Cyprien est raciste ? 9000 retweets ?
-Cyprien, vous êtes raciste. Vous répondez quoi à la polémique ?
J'aime bien Jurassic Park ?
-Abonne toi !